going into the show I thought it could
have some potential but I ended up
leaving it mostly disappointed and
wanting more Ekko is kind of a fresh
like character that I didn't know
anything about so I thought this could
be an interesting miniseries Especially
since one of the writers from better
call saw was working on the show and
Marvel was going to finally dive into
something that was more mature but if
anything I feel like the R-rated
marketing campaign was more of a way to
get people's attention because it was
still pretty PG-13 and the writing was
nothing special which going into the
first major shortfall is that Ekko as a
miniseries is very underdeveloped the
creators try to do a lot with a pretty
short run time because the show is only
3 hours once you subtract the opening
intros and end credits so in this time
they try to tackle a family drama with a
handful of characters an entire
backstory and recap of Hawkeye that
spans the first episode a more detailed
relationship between Maya and Fisk this
Native American power origin and then
the entire War SLC conflict between May
and Fisk I've seen people say that the
show should have been cut down to like 2
hours but I'd actually argue the
opposite Echo needed a much longer
runtime to properly develop all these
different aspects of the show because by
being stretched so thin and trying to
cover so much it in turn isn't able to
properly build up these elements and pay
them off in a satisfying manner like as
an example Maya gets ripped away from
most of her family as a child and then
she returns to her hometown this I think
is is an interesting Dynamic to build
upon relationships but the show is
preoccupied with so much that the
character work never hits a satisfying
depth and you probably wouldn't be
expecting a family drama out of echko
but I honestly found some of it
compelling mainly because the first
episode of the show makes you sympathize
and care about Maya and he want her to
rekindle her past relationships and thus
become happier in life the parallel
between Fisk being a manipulative figure
in a toxic influence versus her Native
American family that wants to truly love
her I thought was pretty good along with
the acting requiring more physicality
and facial expressions since Maya was
deaf and characters interacting with her
had to use sign language if anything I
thought the whole action side of the
show was very underwhelming and was in
general unimaginative this may be a
major turnoff for most of you because
Marvel as a brand is supposed to be an
exciting action-packed Adventure but
that isn't what Ekko is they try to make
it a more grounded drama series with a
strong native American perspective
there's action here but it's Ely not the
selling point of the series which I
think is kind of refreshing but again
since the series is so short and a
stretch so thin I don't think it's able
to hit a high enough quality to really
be worth the time like if you really
wanted a great recent Native American
story then go watch killers of the
flower moon it's basically the same
runtime and that movie is way better to
not purely bash the show I think the
performances in Echo are pretty solid
and it's mostly unfortunate that the
writers couldn't give these characters
more scenes to FL out their Dynamics
hell Maya's best friend has like one
quick and awkward scene with Maya and
she doesn't get any kind of emotional
reconnection with Maya in the end it
feels so rushed and unfulfilling as a
dramatic story that it makes me wonder
if the writer actually wrote it this way
or if they were pressured by The
Producers to make the story shorter or
if there were some budgetary issues like
the premise I think is pretty solid and
should allow for a great story and with
more time in episodes I assume that
could have been the case now going into
the other more inferior half of the show
in my opinion let's talk about the Fisk
and overall War plotline there's a lot
that annoys me and first let's discuss
the relationship between Fisk and Maya
because it largely feels like a retcon
you're telling me that this character
who Fisk has been raising is very close
to him and is a deadly fighter that he
regularly uses never went up against
Daredevil during his show I know Ekko as
an IP wasn't even on Netflix's radar
when they were making Daredevil but Sur
planting her into that narrative when it
doesn't make any sense I think is pretty
jarring like Fisk was on the ropes
fighting for his life using all of his
assets during that show and apparently
Maya was never used she's just been
hiding in the background until now so
that's kind of an aspect that you have
to accept about the story because the
writers want to make Fisk an integral
part of Maya's life when that was never
set up before from here the relationship
between May and Fisk feels rather
inconsistent and confuses me at the end
of Hawkeye she flat out murders Fisk by
shooting him in the face and I was like
wow what an underwhelming way to end
such a magnificent villain and Daredevil
and then after the show they said Fisk
would return in Echo and I was like huh
I was eagerly awaiting the explanation
as to how Fisk would survive a gunshot
wound to the head and apparently all
they did was slap a bandage onto his eye
like Phil Swift plugging a hole of water
with fleux tape it's such a joke of a
way to handle this character and why
would you ever write it to where fist
gets shot in the head and returns that
completely undercuts any stakes in
waight for Death Scenes because if F can
survive a headshot wound then I'm not
going to be concerned about his
wellbeing in the future it's just a
mindboggling writing choice that feels
the same as Sabine getting skewered by a
lightsaber but at least she didn't
sustain a critical injury where her
brain was from here most of the
confrontations between Fisk and Maya are
him approaching her with no defenses as
she has a gun trained on him which seems
confusing to me because if she was so to
kill him then why not do so again I know
Fisk is trying to manipulate her but
most of their shared scenes together he
fails to do so and she for some reason
chooses to not kill him despite her not
really changing much since her first
attempt at trying to take his life she
does change by the end of the show and
without going into spoilers she has a
different solution to fix Fisk as a
problem which just felt really weird it
has to do with her entire power which I
also thought wasn't explained that much
they left it relatively vague and I'm
not sure if that was their intention
because it seems to give her multiple
unrelated Powers but I feel like going
into that would be a spoiler so I won't
do that overall the dynamic between Fisk
and Maya was not convincing because the
writers primarily tell us that they have
this strong bond without really
establishing it like why is Fisk
obsessed with Maya when he has so much
more on his plat what about her does he
love so much why is he going so far out
of his way to be this Father Figure and
raise her the only real motivation they
establish is that Fisk was mostly using
her as a weapon but Fisk has plenty of
those and why would he risk killing her
father when there's a possibility she
could find out to me it all comes across
as forcing May and fist together to try
and make an interesting story without it
seeming realistic especially since she's
non-existent in Daredevil which I could
honestly forgive if they actually
dedicated more time to establishing her
past with Fisk and answering all of
those questions but again that means
more time for telling the story leading
back to the issue of Ekko largely being
under developed also within this half of
the show we have the action side of
things I've seen some people say that
they really liked it but to me I thought
it was pretty flawed it has some great
choreography however I think it's
dragged down by some of its
cinematography and editing the first
action scene with Daredevil uses the
notorious fake Warner that have done
poorly can be really distracting and can
also be a detriment to the presentation
of the action because what's even the
point of Faking a Warner if you're just
going to wipe the camera and hide Cuts
every 3 seconds it's painfully obvious
and since they're trying to create one
continuous shot it leads to some moments
being awkwardly framed there have been
some incredible examples of fake Warners
like Guardians of the Galaxy 3 where the
hidden Cuts aren't as jarring and the
action is always framed in a great way
or you have Daredevil where they
actually do real wers so this action
scene while it does have some great
choreography I think is filmed in a bad
way then for another fight scene the
editing was very sporadic and fast-paced
making the edit overly jarring that and
they would also try to draw parallels to
Maya's Native American past by using
quick cutaways of her ancestors fighting
which makes the edit even more chaotic
and Annoying It's also really sad
because every now and then they'll have
a wides shot longer take showing the
action meaning that this is the level
they could be operating on and then they
butcher it with a bunch of quick
unnecessary cuts and the editor even
utilizes jump cuts for this one shot
there's just so many editing choices
that don't feel well suited for the
action then for an action scene at night
the editor raised the brightness so much
to the point that the black levels look
terrible like why would he even bother
making the scene outside at night if you
were going to butcher the look of your
scene not to mention that this action
scene was overall very unimaginative and
boring it was just Maya running across a
train planting something and then she
jumps off like the writers really
couldn't come up with anything more
interesting or engaging also in these
action scenes they come across as having
barely any impact or Consequences
because Maya always comes away unscathed
she dead ass throws her body off of a
train and gets rocked by a truck that
then heartbreaks and she's a okay she
even has this massive bullet wound in
the side of her torso that gets sewed up
and then literally the scene after this
she climbs an entire water tower like
Maya as a character sustains no physical
punishments that made a show like
Daredevil feel so raw and real the only
thing of consequence that happens to
Maya is that her prosthetic leg gets
crushed but it instantly gets replaced
the fight scenes and Daredevil however
were deeply investing because we knew
that Matt Murdoch was always in danger
because he was sustain life-threatening
injuries but in Echo the writers
couldn't be bothered with doing this
because I guess they don't have enough
time to do so so that in turn makes the
action feel weightless they just throw
some flashy action around and move on
instantly as if nothing happened another
main reason why Daredevil was so great
is that they balanced the action down
time with deep in personal character
development this is what Ekko should
have been and wasn't there's only like a
few action scenes and maybe a couple
emotional dialogue scenes also Maya
literally shows up to her hometown and
jeopardizes everyone's safety by
bringing about a war because of her own
personal Vendetta she's risking the
lives of her entire family every step of
the way and she's even called out on
this but this entire notion is dropped
by the end of the show and is not
explored again there are basically no
consequences for her actions they set up
like six characters in her family and
none of them die which I don't need
there to be character deaths but instead
tangible consequences this in turn makes
the story lack depth because the writers
are acting like this critical conflict
doesn't exist instead they should be
exploring this considerably and even
have ma as a character confront the fact
that what she's doing is wrong thus
changing and evolving her as a character
and the way she changes is through her
rekindling her love for her true family
then the general plot for the overall
War if you can even call it that is so
stereotypic typical and nothing happens
in the story that is remotely
interesting Maya just attacks a compound
and Fisk retaliates briefly and that's
basically it in terms of the plots
there's not a single surprise in the
entire story and it's probably one of
the most generic plots that Marvel ever
created along with a lot of scenes being
filled with dumb moments like Maya
getting captured and one of her
kidnappers kindly giving back her foot
which she uses to get out Maya also
randomly becomes mcgyver in one scene
and makes this complicated invention
despite the skill being established
orist conveniently calling off his men
right before they're about to kill Maya
and hey all this takes place in one
episode so this entire War aspect of the
story isn't just dull but it's also
pretty dumb that's why I'd say the
actual meat of the story is the family
drama which will inherently disappoint
some people and turn others away it does
have some strong moments like the scene
between Ma and her grandmother which was
infused with an endearing emotional
connection but these moments are few and
far between and Aren't Enough To to
redeem the utter mediocrity of Ekko I
don't think Ekko as a show is as bad as
secret Invasion but I wouldn't be
surprised if it gets overrated by Marvel
fans purely because it isn't an
Abomination from my perspective I don't
think this show is worth the time
because there's so many other better
shows and movies to watch thank you for
watching and if you want to see more of
my writing since I don't do videos on
everything I watch then check out my
letter box and my patreon and Discord
links are in the description have a
great day and let me know what you
thought about Ekko in the
comments also thank you so much to Logan
Farmer for being a Monumental Patron and
unlocking the tear of me shouting him
out thank you so
much